all right Eric Palacios from Eric  Palacios and Associates the sponsors of  this segment shares what the penalties  are for a domestic battery in Nevada  hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the  legal minute today's question is what  are the penalties for domestic battery  charge in Nevada first of all Nevada law  defines domestic battery as  intentionally inflicting unlawful  physical force on a current or former  spouse dating partner or certain family  members a first offense is usually a  misdemeanor punishable by fines of two  hundred dollars to a thousand dollars  you have to do 48 to 120 hours of  community service and sometimes you'll  spend two days up to six months in jail  you also have six months to do weekly  counseling if you're accused of domestic  violence it's important that you call an  experienced attorney right away I'm Eric  Palacios this has been the legal minute  give Eric Palacio send us a call or  visit their website at Eric palacios.com  we'll be right